[Music]
the Washington Monument is 555 feet 5
and 1 8 inches tall
the marble and granite are cut around
the stones
[Music]
what's going on up there the shatari
corps is detonated and caused severe
structural damage to the elevator oh no
my friends are up there what uh don't
worry ma'am everything's gonna be okay
excuse me excuse me oh my god let's talk
oh my God look at the ceiling just stay
calm everyone oh we are going to die
here
[Music]
estimating 10 minutes before
catastrophic failure the freaking
screwed okay guys I know that was scary
but our safety systems are working the
safety systems are completely failing
we're very safe in here the occupants
are an imminent mortal danger no I'm
going as fast as I can
foreign
[Music]
you now have 125 seconds until
catastrophic failure what why unexpected
motion has caused the deterioration to
escalate how do we get in there
elevating reconnaissance drum
[Music]
that's awesome
locating optimal entry points
proceed to Southwest window Karen I'm on
my way
[Music]
keep going
okay
what's wrong you've reached the
Southwest window why are you hesitating
never been this high before you have
also not reinstalled your parachute so a
fall from this hike would most likely be
lethal
perfect
why is it not breaking it's orange
ballistic glass you'll have to create
more momentum
[Music]
what are you doing
now return to the ground immediately
return to the ground where we will open
fire go up go up
I got this
[Music]
is your last 10. oh I'm gonna die
hey how you doing don't worry about it I
got you yes yay
sorry sir so sorry
[Music]